l'espionnage est une salle pratique mais
tout le monde le fait c'est une affaire
délicate
le risque est élevé mais la récompense
est tout autant élevé si on réussit on
touche le jackpot sans que personne ne
le découvre jamais de notre côté en cas
d'échec l'embarras peut être énorme
comme ce fut le cas il ya 15 ans tout à
coup à l'époque un diplomate britannique
de haut rang prend la curieuse habitude
de faire des promenades inexplicable
dans les endroits les plus insolites à
chaque fois l'itinéraire est le même la
sonnette d'alarmé n'a pas encore été
tirés mais les services russes de contre
espionnage ont décidé de garder un oeil
sur cette curieuse petite manie
christopher secrétaire archiviste de
l'ambassade du royaume uni à moscou a
l'air aussi louche que possible puis un
autre diplomate britannique prend à son
tour la même habitude et pendant l'une
de ses promenades lors des diplomates
s'écarte du chemin frappe une pierre au
hasard et puis continue sa promenade à
ce moment là la sonnette d'alarmé est
tirée à ce stade le fsb se dit que
quelque chose de louche est en train de
se préparer
il continue son observation et voit
qu'un troisième et un quatrième
diplomate britannique commence à faire
ses petits pèlerinages vers cette petite
pierre à un moment donné un certain marc
d'eau deuxième secrétaire de l'ambassade
de l'époque est signalée comme d'un
agent du mi6 dans les services russes de
contre-espionnage emporte la pierre pour
la polir un peu il s'avère que c'était
un appareil wi fi d' utiliser pour
communiquer avec un fonctionnaire russe
devenu traître
à l'époque cet appareil était un moyen
de pointe pour organiser les liaisons
entre le mi6 et leurs agents en russie
les britanniques ont refusé de
reconnaître ces informations jusqu'en
2012 c'est à cette date que l'ancien
conseiller du premier ministre tony
blair a officiellement reconnu que cela
était vrai cette pierre est ce ton était
embarrassante
il le savait depuis un certain temps et
le gardait pour des raisons politiques
voilà sept pierres dont nous parlons au
plus tôt une copie de celle d'où nous
parlons l'original a été réduite en
poussière avec circuits et fils
électriques
mais cette pierre a causé tant
d'embarras aux services de renseignement
et diplomates britanniques depuis lors
les technologies ont été miniaturisé et
cela a été remplacé par cela l'internet
et les messageries
si les méthodes et des tactiques on peut
changer les objectifs et les stratégies
restent les mêmes
l'espionnage des subterfuges le
renseignement et la trahison
on pourrait se dire que les agents
britanniques et leurs recrues éventuel
en russie aurait pensé à se faire un peu
plus discret à l'avenir mais non le
service fédéral de sécurité de russie a
diffusé de nouvelles images ou le
successeur de marc dos répète c'est
démarche maladroite d'eps james william
thomas stafford entre dans un restaurant
à moscou c'est l'ancien deuxième
secrétaire chargé des affaires
politiques de l'ambassade du royaume uni
ce signal est comme un agent non
déclarés du mi6 marie à elisabeth
greenberg identifié comme agent du
renseignement suédois suivi de 10h au
sov bras droit de alexeï navalni
directeur exécutif de la fondation fbk
il vit actuellement au royaume uni la
surveillance de cette rencontre a été
assurée par les services russes de
contre espionnage qui gardaient un oeil
sur l'agent spécial ford
si nous avions plus d'argent nous
accompagnons bien sûr notre équipe un
peu d'argent si quelqu'un dépensé je ne
sais pas 10 20 millions de dollars par
an pour soutenir cela nous verrions les
choses différemment
et ce n'est pas une grosse somme
d'argent pour des gens qui ont des
milliards en jeu c'est donc le message
que j'essaie de faire passer dans le
cadre de ma campagne de collecte de
fonds notamment en parlant aux gens qui
viennent des affaires etc et donc vous
avez bien compris le clin d'oeil
financer notre arrivée au pouvoir et
nous allons vous rembourser des
milliards laisse entendre celui qui est
pourtant engagée contre la corruption
l'opposition a même un plan qui
ressemble en tous points aux méthodes
dont il accuse le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire de bombarder les électeurs
avec de la propagande ou encore de
négocié des accords avec les élites
qu'elles devront jouer sur plusieurs
tableaux manifestations de masse
initiatives civiles propagande établir
des contacts avec les leaks il lui
expliquait que nous sommes des gens
raisonnables qui ne vont pas tout
démolir ne vont pas leur retirer leurs
biens pour renforçant les rumeurs selon
lesquelles l'opposition reçoit de l'aide
de la part des services de renseignement
étrangers
monsieur h horcoff semble demander
l'aide des britanniques notamment des
informations dont dispose le
gouvernement et les services du
renseignement afin de les utiliser
contre le gouvernement russe
dans certains cas nous n'avons pas de
preuve directe nos preuves sont
indirects je suis sûr que le serious
fraud office a accès à beaucoup
d'informations qui proviennent des
sources britanniques mais qu'ils ne sont
pas disponibles
ici vous savez je suis certain que des
services secrets britanniques possèdent
des informations sur abramovitch
ousmanov sur les personnes au
gouvernement russe je pense que la
grande bretagne est un pays européens
clés qui a un rôle à jouer et qui durcit
déjà sa position envers la russie la
grande bretagne après tout a beaucoup à
gagner à 10h en cov ne tourne pas autour
du pot
l'idée est claire donnez nous des
informations et nous vous aiderons à
éviter la concurrence pour les banques
britanniques en torpillant les banques
us nous allons publier un rapport sur la
banque vtb en collaboration avec la
société envie jackson allumer tous qui
permettra de comprendre ici une courte
pause pendant que la serveuse s'approche
on ne sait jamais elle pourrait être une
espionne qui essaie de les écouter
vtb est impliqué dans la corruption de
la gestion des risques qu'il fonctionne
pas faisant valoir qu'elles représentent
une menace pour les marchés financiers
européens et leur intégrité
parce qu'elle y est un facteur important
et c'est blanc cran la concurrence plus
difficile pour des entreprises
britanniques comme lloyds et rbs ou
barclay's malgré les allusions dash
horcoff ford ne s'en cache directement
en faveur d'aucun soutien financier à la
place où il dit 'ah horcoff de
travailler avec transparancy
international que la grande-bretagne
finance déjà je pense que la législation
sur les agents étrangers sera bien sûr
très importante pour cet automne nous
apportons notre soutien diverses ong
comme beaucoup d'autres ambassades
une fois que cette nouvelle législation
entrera en vigueur en novembre
je pense qu'on y accordera beaucoup
d'attention ils devront faire valoir un
moment ou à un autre ils ne sont venues
des agents politiques et les agents
étrangers
nous finançons un projet dirigé
principalement en ukraine mais aussi
dans d'autres pays de la région sur le
thème du gouvernement d'ouverture
ce partenariat de gouvernement
d'ouverture pour nous en élaborons un
aussi pour la russie nous sommes ouverts
à la coopération
nous ne pensons pas que ça sera efficace
imaginez un homme politique britannique
qui rencontre des agents des services
secrets russes y demande des fonds et
des infos compromettantes sur les rivaux
cela provoquerait un tollé national
en plus des complications éthiques ce
serait sans aucun doute considéré comme
une menace à la sécurité
et c'est exactement ce que c'est aux
yeux du fsb
les agents du mi6 au sein de l'ambassade
pour accomplir leur mission principale
qui est de rassembler des informations
secrètes sur le potentiel militaire et
économique de la russie continue de
participer activement à la coopération
entre l'ambassade et l'opposition russe
et à soutenir diverses ong en leur
fournissant des subventions en plus de
les soutenir en matière d'information et
de financement les agents de l'ambassade
britannique participe à la mise en place
de forces d'opposition ça n'a jamais été
un secret que l'opposition en russie a
des liens avec des gouvernements
étrangers et travaillent parfois dans
leurs intérêts
on verra donc ce que ça donne
probablement c'est ce que je ferai
[Applaudissements]
oui ce n'est pas un petit travail mais
l'intensité de cette coopération
poussera les électeurs à se poser de
sérieuses questions
ça ne crée aucun vite